[Musique]
vous dites maintenant dans ce livre que
sans giono et sans cocteau vous ne
seriez pas ce que vous êtes aujourd'hui
oui probablement singulièrement sans
giono d'abord puisque je les joue je les
ai connu j'avais 19 ans je l' ai connu
j'avais 19 ans et c'est un homme dont je
me suis senti très proche que j'admirais
évidemment si on vous voit l'avenir avec
lui une photo qui était prise par
bernard buffet s'est désolé il a été
prise par bernard du cfc dumont et oui
je vais déjà vais pas de 19 ans les
lyonnais devaient avoir je sais pas quel
âge à l'époque c'était un homme
extraordinaire j'ai fait le voyage à man
à ce que j'appelle ça comme ça parce que
pour moi c'était comme faire le voyage à
la mecque enfin 7 et giono c'était
énorme c'est un immense écrivain
formidable qui à qui je dois beaucoup
qui m'a témoignée lethier affection qui
m'a directeur de conscience morgue en
grande partie je lui dois je lui dois
par exemple la connaissance de la
littérature anglo saxonne
littérature dans lesquelles ils évolué
puisqu'il avait traduit moby dick par
exemple ils connaissent admirablement et
genou m'a fait découvrir d'autres choses
qui peuvent paraître moins important
comme comme la littérature de police
hier je n'étais pas un grand adepte de
la série noire est chester himes pour
lui et est un des plus grands écrivains
c'était quelqu'un de très étonnant
[Musique]